I think my mouth is crying I'm really
looking forward to this grilled cheese
I'm just looking forward to see what's
inside this mysterious expensive
sandwich a little suspicious
the combination of something fancy was
something that's pretty cheap and
standard I'm really interested to see
what a fancy grilled cheese is like
because I believe the best grilled
cheese
it's just Kraft singles and bread I
think she should need to be sliced
triangular that's like an important
thing for me and you know really when it
comes out on the plate if it's not
sliced the way one I'm gonna be like a
little upset you just grab an iron
American cheese two pieces of white
bread and just make this a bread that
might be clubbed smell like a grilled
cheese hi I'm Joe Calderon at
serendipity 3 in New York City and we're
here today to make the quintessential
grilled cheese sandwich which has the
Guinness world record as the most
expensive sandwich in the world what
makes it the quintessential grilled
cheese sandwich well first we start with
this beautiful French Pullman bread that
is baked with Dom Perignon champagne oh
my gosh as you can see it's flecked with
23-karat edible gold what we're gonna do
is take a little white truffle butter
and brush the bread so when we put it in
our panini press it gets a nice crisp
grape flavor then we're gonna use the
creme de la creme of cheeses which is
called cacio Cavallo put Alico cheese
this is from a totally cattle in
southern Italy of which they're only
25,000 of them they graze on aromatic
grasses such as wild strawberry and
licorice and they only lactate in May
and June is that she's similar to
another kind of cheese like a cross
between a manchego and a parmesan but it
melts really well for a grilled cheese
sandwich this is San Marzano an african
lobster tail bisque
oh yes how much does one of these things
cost the quintessential grilled cheese
here at serendipity is 214 dollars ok a
day you've never had lobster bisque and
you also put ketchup on your grilled
cheese so please I'm asking you to take
the first bite
[Music]
[Applause]
amazing okay you're not dipping I'm not
I'm gonna try my first okay
oh my job what do you feel I feel rich
all the flavors have some sort of savory
like salty quality but they all have
their own distinct characteristics the
lobster bisque I ate it makes it
obviously non the sudden you're like
eating seafood it's very different but
it really the flavors complement each
other
you have gold on your lips is the most
extra thing I have ever seen I'm just
gonna save it for later okay I'm just
gonna try a gold flake taste tastes like
gold I'm sorry for whoever goes out with
me I can probably afford like one of
these you might have to get you know
some crushed ice and water I don't tend
to spend 200 plus dollars on my meals
but I like to imagine a time when I'm
just like so freakin wealthy grilled
cheese is a comfort food but like I got
left go from a job like I just needed an
ultimate pick-me-up this is like hey
you're awesome you're doing fine you're
worth it so have this great grilled
cheese are you saying you're having a
bit of a cheese awakening that was very
cheesy
[Music]